[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
in the orchestra yeah beautiful welcome
back to the break room this is our daily
live stream updated all the nerdy news
you need to know uh and all this week uh
and today included this show is brought
to you by Pluto TV which offers hundreds
of free live channels and thousands of
free on-demand movies uh coming up on
the show today Reed Richards has a face
it's stretchy is Jessica GAO thirsty
someone get her a couple Waters I don't
think that awful noise okay what is that
Mike is right there
oh stop no absolutely it's for our ASMR
heads in the chat wait who wears short
shorts
I got all my hoochie daddy shorts today
looking 97 degrees
Thursday night in my coochie Cutters I
gotta tell you
I am back again thank you I'm very happy
they didn't give me G fuel because I
already had a lot of energy anyways I'm
good you came in with an energy drink
damn right I did it was a bomb
why is he drinking a bob out of can yeah
when I went with the bike bomb speaking
of pipe bombs we got a real bombshell
over here it's Jessica Clements
said to me all day and he yelled at me
this morning
I spoke very firmly and with authority
uh speaking of firm with authority
hello everyone I'm always firm that's my
secret by the way if you've been
watching this show and you haven't hit
the like button yet oh get him what's
wrong with you you like it you subscribe
that's how this works you want this
content you liking you subscribe or else
I'm gonna have to get a third job and
show up on some other YouTube channel
and ruin their days okay I'm already
damaging seven people emotionally in
this office every day plus virtually at
another job they'll make me get a third
job like And subscribe side crawl out of
your trash bags hit the like button and
then crawl back in and get covered up
with spiders and worms however you keep
yourself warm I don't care but like this
video that's beautiful
we showed up on those other YouTube
channels they'll be appreciated I'm sure
I'm sure be a big boost for that ratings
uh if you want to send in some super
chats today we'd love to take them we
got a little Redemption going okay uh if
you notice by the thumbnail we're gonna
be talking villains today so for every
fifty dollars that's like fifty dollars
uh we getting super chats we will
villainify validify the villainify
ourselves vilify we'll become more
villainous than we already are Abilify
but it's more Abilify because if we were
to vilify ourselves we would speak ill
of ourselves but I call myself the
resident supervillain anyway so that's
right James the man Titan Jack you
better watch out hence the shirt and
wear whoa they're saying that's because
they ain't us that's right send in those
super chats and for every fifty dollars
we'll get more dastardly more evil more
nefarious you'll see the worst of us you
thought this was bad oh it gets much
worse yeah I'll actually be cycling down
into a normal nice person
tell me so you know you know how you
fight like like answer with chemo you
know what I mean bad on bad you gotta
hit you gotta hit Tommy with the badass
they go from cancer chemo to Tommy
getting
tired Jessica I worship you I don't know
where this is all coming last time
you're on remember when he compared
women yeah this is true yeah so Jezebels
and everything Melissa all I'm saying is
we wouldn't have you know we lost our
our we don't need to walk around naked
if women hadn't been so deceitful oh my
God
don't put me in the shower time I
already gave up a rib
this is how you redeem Tommy women ate
from an Apple so men can eat women well
not the Army Hammer one whoa yeah yeah
no no I love where this is going let's
get you guys
I did not started I was accused of
hating women
by saying I don't hate them I just
believe they're all treacherous and
Liars okay
lucasfilm execs are stepping down at
least one is
um some changes that lucasfilm Michelle
redrawn has stepped down at SVP at
lucasfilm SVP standing here senior vice
president
vampire person or sexy vampires Michelle
we're drawing the sexy vampire person is
stepping down she will return to
producing with an overall deal at
lucasfilms and Walt Disney Studios yeah
I think it's a good deal still around
though why isn't she stepping down then
well I think it was part of they're
doing less Star Wars movies you know
what I mean that
that's not like they're playing anymore
originally lucasfilm was like two Star
Wars films a year
and then they gave us two Star Wars
films a year and we didn't like it it
was like uh what is that Nutrisystem not
Nutrisystem Slim Fast Slim Fast one two
two movies a day and a sensible dinner
there you go that's how you do Star Wars
boom good to know noted noted up here
Walter Ramada DC's film boss has left
Warner Brothers you guys but I feel like
we knew okay
[Applause]
goodbye thank you you Walter Ramada is
officially stepped down as a head of DC
films though we knew he would be leaving
this position as part of the Warner Bros
Discovery merger yeah yeah it's on new
news we didn't know when he was called
in water is wet news yeah Walter Hamada
is gone yeah this guy is blue news uh
this guy's leaving so I mean it's
interesting that it's happening right
before a DC movie comes out like the
weekend of yeah
do you think um do you think this was
already like set in stone and all right
it was already the motion was going it's
not yeah
we didn't know the date exactly when
he'd be fully stepping down but I I
think it's interesting because it's a
beautiful time because of everybody
knows what the Cameo is in Black Adam
there's no no secret it's because Dwayne
went over his head yeah
yeah Dwayne because he was like Hamada
was like I'm never bringing him back I
got other plans for Superman and then
twins was like okay let me make this
phone call to the head of Warner
Brothers films directly and they was
like yeah bring them all back oh I I
okay yeah that makes me Dwayne woke up
in the morning he ate 13 boiled chicken
breasts we went to zazlov's house at 4am
which is out in the his front yard
lifting zab's Labs car above his head
and he was like fire Hamada he's fired
you guys remember when The Rock had the
the app that was like the mo they think
it was called The Rock clock and it was
like no it was like a motivational app
where like it was it was actually kind
of a it was a good thing like it was
like The Rock will motivate you to like
do your goals whether it's working out
or learning a language or getting work
done and you could set an alarm that
would be like this is Dwayne Johnson
time to wake up and grind and that's not
Dwayne Johnson's impression I'm not
getting a person
Wayne Johnson impression finally
The Rock has come back to your cell
phones that would be better I would like
that one the only celebrity app I ever
used was the Jeremy Renner app
what is wrong with you
I was addicted I put money in it
she likes for the character of She-Hulk
Jessica sees the She-Hulk series as her
uh as her complete origin story and now
what comes next will be the new version
of the character she says after going
through those initial Growing Pains now
she fully has become She-Hulk and with
that comes the confidence and the
experience and maybe a little bit more
hubris hubris yeah there you go that
really opens up a very different version
of she-hul I hope so I love a different
version I mean she just gonna get more
now she's gonna be able to just
literally just smash all type of dudes
plus Matt Murdoch across country yeah I
think that when we saw it was like not
misleading at all I think that it's just
more so that when we saw him with the
family at the end didn't mean that they
were like together I think they're still
not like not like Anonymous they're
friends with benefits just say it Jess
they're friends with benefits yeah
are they different when she changes yes
then they have more little dots
guys call in if you know
boobs uh we got some new concept art for
Kevin k-e-v-i-n uh from the She-Hulk
series look at how crazy these are wild
look at how crazy this is one is like
the Tower of Terror from Disney's the
one on the far right I like though I
like bottom left and I like top right
yeah
because I can't see anything you don't
have to move you don't have to well you
can't see it I can't see a thing I'm
just bottom bottom left and top right
are essentially the same right what are
those yeah they're very simple there's
some little changes of up I mean like
the top left one like that's very Matrix
right it looks like a sentinel
tiger the little HD guy yeah the other
two look like uh it's even Borderlands
Brandon said a really funny joke and
said yeah my dentist at the bottom right
it definitely is what they do it looks
like a hot water heater
I'm really happy with what they went
with yeah I think they came up with a
good design also the one that they came
I'm sure there's a lot of designs for
Kevin also all those little ones just
had little hats on it but I think um
choosing one that is more resembles film
over time makes more sense to steal a
tweet from Brandon uh the one we got is
like can we get Kevin and then ma the
bottom right one is we have Kevin at
home we have Kevin at home the wish
version a giant box uh and as a surprise
to nobody to knock where to have felt a
little ashamed about one aspect of
Neymar's clothing you guys want to take
a guess don't look at the screen you
guys want to take a guess yeah okay them
shorts they're short now that's the only
thing I feel like clothing in your hands
I was gonna say maybe it's his little
feet no because they gave him bigger
Wings than in the comments because in
comics Neymar's Wings is like this they
gave him chicken wings then from
Church's Chicken which are those steroid
Wings you don't know about like I know
about Churches Chicken look at me of
course I know I thought she was just
gonna say Popeyes Church kid of course I
know Popeye's Chicken I know Pollo vert
I know uh Pollo Loco I know Raising
Canes what other chicken places
Zaxby's is in the South KFC Bojangles
anybody good good come on but Church's
wings are made out of steroids and
steroids and uh black churches and so
black bishops and so that's why his
wings are like that but like instead of
the comics where he's like how does he
fly with the little flutters in the
comments well there's a lot of debate
about that right uh sorry Jessica we're
totally stepping over your story but
like the idea that name or Neymar is a
mutant and his power is flight but the
flight power is not from the wings he's
got some other sort of like levitational
device they think the wings help with
like gliding them right when we see him
like kind of pitching around in the
trailer that's like part of what the
wings because the wings aren't creating
like a plane you know like they have the
ailerons and stuff up and down to move
around yeah these are his little like
runners okay but he had something like
innate fly power I don't know if they'll
change that and what kind of forever and
be like yeah they're flap art enough to
make them fly how strong is the bone of
them ankles
wow also wouldn't you be like feet first
in the end upside down
to the right Jay was correct it is the
shorts yeah uh he referred to the iconic
skimpy green shorts as his shame shorts
oh I had a pair of Shame shorts but they
were simple for another reason uh go on
let's unbox this I just kind of used
them okay shame shorts are like your
last pair under where you were on like
yeah laundry day that had too many holes
they're just there's just more hole than
wear yeah yeah my best friend his father
got arrested Soul had a pair of Shame
shorts but they were regular shorts they
were like khaki shorts and they would
come up to like right below the testicle
and he would wear them outside to
embarrass my boy and he'd be like Dad
could you go to the house I'd be like I
don't know when it slips he had a belt
on with him too that was the thing oh no
he hit the shortest ball foul
it happens more than you think Dad's
wearing them shorts
shave shorts uh since he wore them on
the uh on the Walk of Shame from his
trailer to set and back when filming uh
he refers to them as the same shorts
because he fell he wasn't physically
ready to wear something so revealing to
say yet here's the thing we were talking
about this though like they give actors
a robe yeah you only have to be about
the idea that he's walking back and
forth that was him
I don't want to brag but I've done a few
shoots uh in television where I have had
to wear pretty revealing outfits or no
outfits at all there's never been a time
and maybe it's maybe to knock where to I
assume is a more pleasant man to see
undress than myself but I have had
people insist upon a robe upon it let me
tell you would you like a second robe
for your robe oh Jesus should we put you
should we put a robe over that how about
a tarp over you do your mind
they transported Tommy like Juggernaut
like an X-men too he's like in several
several armored trucks
look I've been doing squats and leg
exercises I'm wearing these short shorts
you're gonna see all this stuff yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying I'm around
this this Slugterra
right you will all look good damn meat
right here
there is no safe space
um also I was on set once and I wasn't
very revealing clothes and they didn't
give me a damn thing there's a reason
there's a reason though this is a high
level Marvel film I like to think maybe
they gave everything
I don't know were you in a Marvel film
no oh I'm sorry maybe they gave him a
robe but it was like cuts and it still
showed the shorts
we have a very little discussion so I'll
just go back to the next one no it's
okay I love this bit
um if the projections are right what
kind of forever should make at least 175
mils
yeah could you imagine just having a
little bit of that uh it's opening
weekend from November 11th to the 13th
and that's only for North America wow
black panther debuted uh to 202 million
domestically in 2018 and this would
place it just under Multiverse Madness
and firmly above Thor 11 Thunder it's
expected I mean I think it's gonna make
more better than multiple I do too I
don't think so
I mean when Multiverse of Madness came
out the concept of the Multiverse teased
so many possibilities and I think a lot
of people went to that movie thinking
they were going to see some version of
everything they loved yeah Marvel as a
variant or as someone from a different
different uh different Multiverse so I
feel like that movie maybe had a huge
opening and then the town may not have
been as strong I don't know I could be
proven wrong I feel like something like
black panther people are so confused
about like well it's it's moving on from
Chadwick where does this movie go thank
you for looking at me so respectfully no
I looked at your shirt because I like it
I think your number one hands into a
shirt I was this to his argument but I
think I feel like black panther is going
to have he's gonna do huge numbers but
we'll probably
maintain a higher level and ultimately I
would assume outgrowth Multiverse
tremendous that's my prediction I don't
think it'll do what the first did as far
as 13 weeks and number one right I think
that was just that was an anomaly that
nobody could ever believe I think it's
going to do several weeks and number one
yeah I do think for those who are not
prepared you're going to see a lot of
black people in all white don't get
scared okay we are having a ghost
children
if you live in the south you see a
budget like oh God they just come back
for me like that's not gonna happen but
you're gonna see a lot of like it's
going to be a celebration like a lot of
people are going around the celebratory
Garb and stuff like that because I know
I'm supposed to be going to the premiere
and I got my all-white coming I got
linen so everyone's doing all white hey
oh yeah I'm too nervous are you going to
the premiere I might be I'm bringing
some extra clothes just in case I
ordered a brown I ordered only chocolate
chocolate you gotta you gotta bring up
the Disneyland ring Poncho you know what
I mean tell yourself I'm bringing some
Scotch Guard I'm bringing it I'm
bringing a tide stick everything
into the Black Panther oh I'm going uh
full name or shorts you know what I mean
I'm gonna represent Neymar at the movie
you know and I'll simply be dressed as
Dr Doom AKA Everett Ross
I'm not going to the premiere I wasn't
invited I'm going as a plus one like I
can never get to a Premiere but I
haven't been to any premieres they don't
love me on the internet I've been doing
this internet and stuff so long
enough I'm sorry jay we're gonna get you
tickets to uh I don't know whatever I'll
even go to the marbles we're gonna get
you I'll go to the marbles we're gonna
get you one of the Christmas story too
or this is I'm gonna fight you if you
give me the Christmas tree it's
technically the third one but I don't
want to get into that's a good point
speaking of third Christmases Barry
kogan in an interview with up rocks
reveals he doesn't know about eternals
too which I don't think anyone really
does I don't think Patton Oswald knows
what he's talking about let me get into
this okay so he hasn't been contacted
about it Barry kogan kilgan and he
constantly reaches
and hopes he's heard something even
about appearing in San Diego Comic-Con
because Camille just knows comic books
and so he's like maybe you know
something that I don't know maybe it's a
secret but also this this is enough for
me to be like I don't think that knows
what knew a lot yeah I think he just
said it and was like oh shoot right Pat
Oswald was probably added three months
before they were supposed to drop the uh
yeah yeah like Patton Oswald went there
where they was doing all principal
photography so he don't know they're
like yo you just gonna put this little
suit on with these dots it's also easy
to make those like little mistakes of
even like you know how we even hear Eric
boss will like go in on like past 10
past tense present tense what you say to
make sure it like actually coincides
with what's happening so I think he just
let that work like that slip and was
like oh I shouldn't have well he
probably assumes they were working on it
in their journals too and they probably
are I'm sure it's on a board so I'm
serious they said it is happening though
wow I mean it is probably happening but
not in Phase five or six obviously I
don't think it'll be in phase six I
didn't know they still have some empty
slots like it's probably coming down the
line look they gave us 12 people we got
to see some of them and that's the
harder that's also the hard thing is
like okay so three are off world and
three are also still awful
I'll get into it today Oscar Isaac keeps
the Moon Knight season 2 train and going
back
we're going to the North Pole oh not
safe not the same not the difference
I thought he should ask his pants I was
like what's crazy
Oscar Isaac was being Coy on whether
Moon Knight would appear in a new season
or an upcoming project but it confirmed
that he's had talks with Marvels about
the car that talk with Marvel about the
character's return
sure okay
last last headline last headline finally
finally big MCU casting news Jeff
Schneider who initially broke okay so
listen to this he initially broke both
the blade and uh blade director and
Harrison Ford Thunderbolt Ross news is
reporting that Adam Driver has met with
Marvel about playing either Reed
Richards or Doctor Doom
rumor big Rumor Mill but he's been right
about two things so far off to deny the
fact that this dude is two for two shout
out to the homie Jeff Snyder I worked
with him at collider it's a good friend
Schneider at collider
all right
that wasn't a joke it just rounded it
felt like it deserved a rim shot I guess
you're somewhat of an Insider
see what you did and it did it's kind of
it's kind of maybe yeah yeah but Adam
Driver can only be Reed Richards because
he has a long face already
gotta do the stretching once his face
fits like this but reader I think he'd
be a better reader he'd be a better read
because his face already stretches out I
mean he's been mostly villains no I
don't want kylo Ren as Doctor I don't I
don't I do not want that right Reed
I want Susan just sit there just like I
don't believe nothing in your face I
agree with myself God wants him as Dr
Doom right someone in the chat said
Glenn Howerton for re Richards I don't
want that so bad yeah it's always sunny
and Philadelphia yeah
Liam neesons
Liam neesons I made a picture a long
time ago okay uh I would like to see a
Fantastic Four where Dr Doom uh Johnny
Storm uh and the thing are all older
they're like 20 years older than both
Reed and Sue which I think would be like
a fun way to approach this topic when
you have like a younger read and Sue who
are like gung-ho and they're messing
with stuff they shouldn't mess with and
you have these older characters being
like no no you're you're being too uh
risky with science here you're messing
with things you shouldn't mess with and
it's these two younger people that kind
of create the problem that spreads the
powers amongst everybody I would like to
play with that Dynamic of age and stuff
but I want to you know I want a younger
okay what about Jon Hamm uh he's Mr
citizen yeah yeah BBC Jon Hamm just
loving himself never because that's what
Mr Sinister is he just loves himself he
only wants to have sex with himself like
if it ain't Nathaniel Essex if we went
older I would give like a
I think it'd be fun to put like Pedro
Pascal's Doctor Doom
um GSU Eagle 117 once Danny DeVito is
Doom can you do daily
you do what I'll do it you do it or I'll
do it
ah Ray Richards
Charlie bring my wolf Cola I just bang
Sue storms
the thing is the big Rocky bastard huh
this is called the blacksmith I needed
to stretch out the Cod piece because of
my dude
it doesn't fit all right we ran a pole
folks we ran a pole
Adam Driver for Dr Doom 58 wow a little
over the margin of era people want Adam
looks like saying Adam Driver that is
crazy I don't want kylo Ren as Doctor
dude it would appear though that when it
comes to Adam Driver being Reed Richards
that plan
is doomed oh
George Clooney is Doctor Doom oh I would
like that Christoph Waltz only if they
give Kristoff wants us the thing oh they
give Doom the nipples in the suit like
they did George Clooney's Batman suit
yes
I'm also a big proponent of them doing
some Marvel starting messing with gender
of characters and swapping them they
have not really done so Victoria vandu
well I would like a female Doom I think
would be very interesting
oh okay have you looked at Brigitte
Nielsen's face she would be perfect to
be doctored since Victoria doom on this
very show who's the woman the blonde
lady from glow
I also think they should switch Sue and
read and make sue stretchy and read
invisible you miss incredible yeah yeah
it's already been done
let's talk about these villains okay
okay yeah get this board out we are
currently in the emergency room of the
MCU if you didn't know it folks wait too
short I can help I mean I said she's a
powerful independent woman
we're in this Multiverse Saga you know
Kang is going to be the overall big bad
that's what they've told us you know
we're ending it all with like uh Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars uh but there's
plenty of other villains that are going
to show up
right now in Phase five and phase six so
we're gonna go through these villains
and see how they might connect to each
other like connect to other properties
and if they might be working for Kang or
working under King and not even know it
or if like never we'll never see them
again okay so let's first go through the
properties and list out our villains
here okay do we want to start and go
this way yeah yeah we'll go in order
okay so we have
wakanda forever
followed by
Quantum Mania
you can take it on that side effect
we'll talk about it oh yeah so ground
forever we got Neymar of course the
first mutant and Dr Doom potentially I
really believe he's the reason
everything started Namor uh I think yes
he wants to be the protector of wakanda
after everything has happened but more
so everything that happened in Infinity
War probably affected Atlantis as well
so that's my thoughts on that real quick
uh we got Quantum Mania and we know who
Kang is because we saw him already in
the Loki series come
on
we got a disaster disaster
Tommy just knocked over someone's coffee
and is all over the floor oh that's
sweet it's still coming
because we almost didn't make it
I think you did that on purpose now do
you want me again so we got Quantum
Mania we saw carrying in love songs
you got it we have Quantum Mania which
is we've seen Kang and uh Loki we've
already seen a lot of what King's gonna
have to offer with all of his different
variants coming through I don't think we
need to get too much into that but Modoc
is also supposedly supposed to be in
quantumania and we know Modoc is just
like a super genius and engineer that
was built and basically overseas Aim so
there is a potential that we could see
aim I really think that he's just gonna
be kind of a henchman two King in
guanamania so those are the two and how
they coincide and maybe we can get more
into it later how they'll go into the
rest of this stuff yeah and that Kang it
might be like a warrior version of King
well it might not be the main Kang we
don't know but it'll be a king because
we could get a mortise and that's the
most violent version of Kane and
immortus could be the one that's really
that's really important yes
uh so then we'll have the show secret
Invasion okay and of course that's gonna
have a lot of skrulls in it uh but it
might introduce like super Scrolls uh
it's got to It's gotta have that which
is this this if you have super Scrolls
you have Scrolls impersonating uh like
Heroes with powers because they can get
power cannot replicate power right but a
super scroll can yep perfect and then we
have Echo
um and Daredevil born again but Echo and
Daredevil Morgan probably is gonna and
ultimately be Kingpin which we've seen
Wilson Fisk and we saw how we last saw
him in Hawkeye yeah Hawkeye uh where he
got beat but clearly not beat enough not
beat enough and shot in the face clearly
who even knows what happened to him
I get shot in the face and still get up
and go
Guardians of the Galaxy volume three
yeah so Guardians of the Galaxy is also
coming and we have Adam Warlock who is
the most perfect being on the planet in
the universe and this Adam Warlock could
potentially be the one where the high
high evolutionary did eventually end up
adopting him and they became uh the out
of warlock became kind of like a
Superman to a different version of Earth
called Uh current
I can't remember but it was like Earth 2
basically which was created by the high
evolutionary so what we know from
guardians galaxy vol 3 is the high
evolutionary doesn't look as you know
scary as he does in the comics but the
high evolutionary is still a very strong
like being almost up they like can they
put them in the same category with a lot
of gods in a lot of higher ups like
basically the eternals just because he's
like really really smart uh but we can
talk about where we think they're going
to go eventually but Adam Warlock I
think is going to start bad and turn to
good so I don't think he's really going
to be on this list the Marvels the
Marvels has we think ale Don I said I'm
gonna pronounce it uh there's a actress
slated for this film I forget her name
uh but the rumors she's playing Eldon in
the comics Eldon is male So Great China
shopping love it already uh this is like
a Cree character who's unhappy with how
the cree have been managing things and
that would make sense uh in the MCU
because the Creed keep [ __ ] up uh so
El Don is probably gonna try and take
over the cree come after Miss Marvel get
like or Captain Marvel I apologize and
Monica and Miss Marvel and get their
powers that they have all obtained I
think through an infinity stone but I
can't wait to see the beef that Monica
and Carol had that's gonna be the real
people because that's the biggest beef
because remember Carol's Monica's mad
Carol never really came back for her mom
more than anything else not the not the
battle and end game right that when
Maria was dying she was mad she never
came back
Loki season two
season two or as I call it Loki part duh
well all we really know right now is
Miss minutes is out there still reading
yeah wreaking havoc what do we know
about Miss Bennett's not too much is she
a king variant is she Zola and surprise
is she I could I mean he was using your
hand so I felt like hey you want to do
the double twist motion
all right thank you
Iron Heart Will feature the hood a man
that we know originally the comics got
his powers from dormammu but it appears
due to some casting rumors that have
been basically confirmed he'll be
getting his powers from Mephisto yeah or
you can catch these fists yo uh and then
I believe Mephisto will be carrying on
over to Covenant of chaos because I mean
Agatha
is you know she was the villain in one
division but she's the titular character
of Covenant of chaos I believe she's
going to be breaking good I don't think
so I think she's still to be bad but I
think there's just a level of bad above
her problem there's a hierarchy of bad
news
listen yeah she's just gonna have the
blue method and the clear Methodist
you'll have a gus bring he knows the
whole thing about a show there's a
hierarchy of evil okay and right now
Agatha is lower on the hierarchy of evil
than whoever she's gonna face in that
show what's going on it's post
post production Daredevil born again no
oh well I didn't know if he was finished
I am now
oh you punched Daredevil born again
again is Kingpin so what we've seen so
far is the same situation we don't know
if he's gonna be
limping from Hawkeye we don't know is
even there's also just like the
potential that Kingpin isn't the
ultimate big big big yeah we don't know
again this is like based on more of what
has been said in the Press what we know
about these shows there obviously could
be more villains involved that we
haven't been told about but yeah Kingpin
will probably definitely have down there
uh Captain America new world order so
Captain America inward because that's
what that really is oh my God
I believe that's what a lot of people
get to see NWA
absolutely inward uh we know the lead is
going to be in there Samuel Stearns you
got to watch the uh original Incredible
Hulk not the Hulk movie not the Eric
Bana one no only you got to watch the
one where Samuel Stearns gets the blood
of his head and all of a sudden he looks
like he has a massive migraine or tumor
it's not the tumor huh I said that's the
only one right no well Jesus no so the
leader will play a part in that but I
think also because Thunderbolt Ross has
been cast Harrison Ford Thunderbolt Ross
will become Red Hulk now somehow some
way I think this movie will bring either
Bruce or Jennifer in because I think
that tease of I'll see you on the big
screen yeah and She-Hulk was for this
because there would be no reason for the
leader to pop up
to this there's too many people in New
World Order I can't stand you know what
I'm saying like there's no reason for
these two to be there without another
Hulk yeah without another hope you don't
think it will be like whole culture it
could be that's what I'm saying you can
either have Bruce or is he the Bruce I
mean I don't think Bruce will be out
here doing Daddy things with scar
playing catch would you consider
Abomination as if you're are we saying
big greens are we saying hulks because I
could see Abominations well leader has a
whole thing of hoax yeah the thing is he
still has samples of Bruce's blood so
he's constantly been trying to replicate
it so here's a bunch of hoax
New World Order is too thick with
ingredients there are too many bad guys
in it
Thunderbolt Ross Bruce Banner
the leader
all of these villains the broth is too
thick we must thin the broth oh we have
to start taking people the content broth
what is on your head
we don't really know the bad guy in
Thunderbolts right but we assume like
Thunderball Russell probably oh yeah
well does salmon Stern's turns that are
but we're also getting Red Hulk right he
actually is the reason Federal Ross yes
well in the comics God dies
no I didn't mean I didn't
I'm not mad at you
start taking yeah
who's like one-off villains that
probably won't I'll go first I'll go
first I'll go first and I'm sorry
everyone I'm sorry are you in the
Heights fans Hood's done
this is the key to this we're going to
introduce him here everyone's gonna go
Sasha bear and Cohen the comedic genius
dramatic actor good at all of this we
love him as Mephisto only one episode in
Iron Heart yeah that's because he's a
series rag on coven of chaos do you
think he's working with kangano or
Kang's manipulating him at all well we
what do we know about Mephisto Mephisto
is a man who basically as we said
earlier this week on the break room he
rules a pocket Dimension that he kind of
formulates to look like hell right and
he behaves as Satan uh or or like the
human interpretation of the devil in
order to manipulate humans and make
Faustian Bargains devilish Bargains it
makes sense for him to be in the coven
of chaos okay I don't know about the
Kang connection copyright pending yet uh
but I do believe Mephisto seems like the
type of person that never truly works
with anyone but himself right like he
will work with whoever helps him get his
goals done and Kang will see right
through that which I could see leading
to a very gruesome death of Mephisto
in phase six
gotcha period if I had to guess
Modoc stays Kang stays of course we know
that's the overall right right this guy
stays to the end too Namor is a one-off
yeah well villain wise yeah was a
one-off I agree with you and that with
uh the high evolutionary warlock is
going to be good yeah eventually so I
think they're in the same boat but I
think High evolutionary is done after
yes so we'll put them here yeah like
Neymar he won't be a bad guy I don't
think by the end of the movie he's the
protector of Atlantis he's not even
really the douchebag he's just like I
got short shorts on I got a bunch of
people I got to take care of now I think
like Miss minutes
that that's different but like the
missed minutes we know will not be the
same right of like Loki season two but
miss minutes could definitely be part of
King's plan is there a possibility sorry
jay is a possibility
is there a possibility that Miss minutes
is Zola just programming I like himself
like that is the next evolution of Zola
it's not his minutes but how would I
think the question is that's a good
thought but like how would he know like
of course the the for some reason Nazis
and all these scientists were genius and
just knew everything and knew about like
algorithms and stuff like that but how
would Zola know
what the TBA is also you know what I'm
saying well you know what I've always
said behind every sexy clock
is a German scientist get out of here
um are you talking about cogsworth
talking about Carl's Ice oh uh Swiss
watch you did mention a really good
theory that we'll be on Rogue Theory
this weekend about how Zola is going to
actually enter Kevin
the robot oh well and I think if if if
Shield or any if there was any computer
or someone typed down about the TVA yeah
then Zola would know about it right yes
yeah if anyone on Earth knows about the
TVA if Shield or sword or anything like
that like they'll know what Zola would
know about it I think also the leader is
just won an incent to the raft I think
he sent to the raft I don't think he's
like build him in the pocket again the
thing is uh where's where where is he
where is he who Modoc I think Modoc and
the leader are gonna get together okay
they haven't you're right and that's why
I think these years
from the Thunderbolts that's why you're
right I forgot about that I mean and
obviously ow Dan I don't think we'll see
al-dan beyond the Marvels but I do think
the Marvels could have a key to King in
a weird way sure because yeah I like to
think that like all of the Marvels right
Monica uh uh Captain Marvel and Miss
Marvel it's obvious how Captain Marvel
is connected to like an infinity stone
that's like literally where her powers
came from from the Tesseract Monica gets
her powers passing through the hex which
is part which is from an infinity stone
age which is from an infinity stone and
then Miss Marvel I think will somehow be
connected to an infinity stone as well
her powers are Cree create you think
it's full the bangle is Cree yeah it is
the bangle is cree and so and also at
the very the post-credits scene of Miss
Marvel Carol has one on
people forget people didn't pay
attention to that they just saw Brie
Larson was like oh it's her if you look
at her left wrist she has the exact same
bangle okay that Kamala has on okay was
this the one that took away her powers
uh because I know she had an inhibitor
that was like a Cree inhibitor right in
the movie
um so we think these ones are staying I
think I think squirrels and super skulls
will be around yeah you'll never get rid
of them because they're everywhere
that's a great McGuffin for any movie
yeah can we move the ones that we so we
think this one's gonna stay no no I
don't think our Dan will stay but I
think people like this game I think Dr
Doom would work with Kang in like a
weird way he's obsessed with Kang so
that was what they'd be a king so that
was the thing I said I was telling you
before we started for those who don't
know the comic book history he actually
tries to trick Kane because at one point
Doom thinks he's Kang's and descending
right right but in all acts Raleigh Kang
is from Reed Richards so but I think
this is the dude in comics that took on
the entire Marvel Universe and this
destroyed it Kane couldn't do what very
other people they did it in the sense
but Dr Doom is the remember this whole
thing these whole next few phases are
Science and Technology mixed together
yeah this is the main person who knows
it okay animal magic so these are magic
these are our babies these are the
villains these are your villains for
phase five
classes
she's the evilest one of everybody
please clap now it's clap get through
the Xbox because I got [ __ ] to do here
for mandatory okay I got great news
about the ads Bob folks we just want to
remind you all that Pluto tv offers
hundreds of free live channels and
thousands of free on-demand movies check
out Pluto TV it's free it's time for
mandatory fun
well they weren't ready for the ground
mandatory fun the segment that we got to
get through fast so we play the graphics
only one more match
again yes mandatory fun the segment
where I get three of my best friends in
the whole wide world to get together
with me and have some fun that they
can't get out of we said goodbye for now
to some iconic villains in the MCU but
with phase five we will be saying hello
for now to some new baddies and I
thought for mandatory fun today we would
let some of these bad guys formally
introduce themselves with a segment I
call villain First Impressions
everybody exit Jessica you're gonna come
in first how this is gonna work
I'm going to give you an index card
you're going to be that villain and you
are going to give your introduction
speech to the universe to me you know
how a villain like in a Bond movie or an
X-Men movie or Marvel movie is like
I've been here for thousands of years
blah blah blah anyway so Jessica we have
you lined up as the villain Modoc here's
some information from Modoc I need you
to give me
your speech right now
as Modoc huh you want me to hit these
yeah and you can put anything else you
want in as well
I am Modoc the mental organism organizes
them organism I can't read my own thing
but I'm smart I promise organism design
only for killing I think the K Used To
Be A C at first but now it's a k because
I kill and I murder people
um the enemy of Captain America but
everybody's an enemy of me I hate
everybody but I hate everybody because
I'm smarter than everybody and because
my papa owns aim and I own aim by proxy
they follow me for some time and then
they get rid of me because I suck but I
don't actually suck I have a lovely wife
and child and no no other villains have
families sir this is a McDonald's
could you just place your order
[Music]
strawberry banana smoothie okay one
strawberry banana smoothie
chickens two we don't you're trying to
play God here okay
I get what I want all right two double
McChickens before the large headed man
with tiny legs did you know that I was
almost married once I did did you know
Catherine W yes Wayne's something
Katherine Wayne's word Wayne's World and
I'm obsessed with the Cosmic Cube ah oh
and I need the cosmic cubic yeah okay so
I'm gonna die eventually eventually and
then they're gonna ask me to come back
to create the Cosmic Cube is that your
whole order though
are you guys out of the pumpkin spice
pies uh the pumpkin cream pies no we
still we still have those that's what
it's a real menu item
it's a real menu right now I work at
McDonald's so I know that they have
pumpkin cream pies okay
anyway uh your order will be right up it
comes to 9.87 I will not pay for it that
is a recession thank you have a nice day
uh okay uh all right sir uh next up we
have Brandon Barrick you will be taking
on uh another person known as the leader
oh okay all right okay go ahead let's
see here
you thought I was dead or maybe just
gone and maybe they forgot about my
character but this is I the leader you
saw me in 2008 that was a fox joint you
know what I'm talking about I ruined
Banner's wedding to Betty Ross and that
that jerk doesn't deserve to be happy
why can't I get married huh why Won't
Anyone married me sir this is an Arby's
oh okay okay
uh well as my head grows larger much
like the beef and Cheddars I get smarter
I once brought Thunderbolt Ross back to
life are you gonna are you gonna order
anything uh yeah let me get uh I will do
a big beef and cheddar okay uh make sure
I get tons of hoisey size in there
please okay uh two potato cakes uh a
market for a sandwich a jamoka shake uh
and curly fries please uh the market for
a sandwich there's six six options did
you want our hand carved roasted turkey
or did you want a uh roast beef and
cheddar or what what did you want I I
want you to know that She-Hulk can't
even beat me because I uh I have great
defense against gamma radiation damage
ah yes I think you're referring to the
multiple times in court that you have
one case is yes based on the defense
that people who are infected with gamma
radiation cannot be held responsible for
their actions yes my greatest power is
utilizing the legal system yes your
total is 13.95 because Arby's is too
expensive uh do you guys take
yeah we take that great thank you uh go
ahead we'll call your number when it's
ready hey can I have the code to the
restroom yes but it says 666. uh okay
next up we have another person uh
introducing himself to the MCU
H go on ahead I can't even get
comfortable for a second okay oh are you
all right sir your face is a nightmare
I am the supreme leader of the nation of
ludveria okay my nation has been
toiled and boiled over with all of you
Heroes and zeros I am born in Romania I
camped on the outskirts of Liberia I
went to State School okay my parents
they gave me scholarship uh-huh
my armor is Enchanted it was created
with the health of Tibetan Monks
they got mags I told them I couldn't
sleep on the bed and I was like yo I got
to get a mattress bro my back is bad but
no
I freed my mother's doomed Soul oh I got
my father to pay child support sir this
isn't Wendy's
what about your father my father uh he's
around he he works as a as a mechanic he
has a little uh little machine my father
is dead I'm so sorry did you want to
order or what's going on here what do
you have that is for strength uh magic I
mean it's probably the Baconator uh that
is magically diabetes okay uh well that
would be the frosty I bet she works
dipping the fries in the frosting Yeah
we actually our machines always work
we're not McDonald's where the machine's
frequently broken
how good are your fries I mean people
say now better than ever and why are you
not in Liberia well certainly how dare
you discriminate against my people with
the Wendy's oh okay uh so did you want
to order anything or okay go ahead I
like strawberry lemonade okay we do
actually have that it's called it's
called Dave's favorite it's fresh
squeezed juices yeah great all right uh
what I'm gonna have for chicken uh well
we have spicy chicken nuggets regular
chicken nuggets sandwiches uh spicy
chicken sandwich the pretzel bacon
chicken sandwich for a limited time well
it's a pretzel roll brush you sir you
don't need to crush me and again I gotta
there's a big line for me behind you and
I think we got a school bus load full of
children coming in later so if you take
lead very and EBT we actually do take
the only EBT we accept is lead very
indeed YouTube
you are good in my book all right well
I'll call you when your number's up oh
you just you just handed me a severed
finger take it okay all right okay
Doctor Doom everybody uh all right last
but not least there is one more villain
we want to introduce okay oh producer
John's here to introduce himself and uh
you're gonna be doing it and please
remember the rules you have to read
everything on the card okay
great
hello
hi
uh it's good to be here today I I I'm
usually not walking around too often oh
boy because I live in a little husk a
little shower
yes you do yes my farts make the Cocoon
smell very bad oh are you out of warlock
no no I am Adams oh sir this is eclair's
jewelry oh are you sure you want to get
yourself up
here okay this is great I I am the
perfect man who was perfect without a
little septum piercing yeah look here's
what you need to know about me before we
get this going okay I like to put
ketchup on my steaks
and I would love to put a little ketchup
it's the perfect way to eat a steak Miss
McMahon hey
go ahead yes all right uh we are selling
jewelry 15 pairs of earrings for a
dollar if you want and they guarantee
them every question I have a question
for you Sean yeah uh have you seen the
lady Chef around here or perhaps a girl
yeah but last time you saw lady Sif was
when you were first hatched out of your
cocoon and you attacked her and tried to
marry her you're right that's because I
shimped for a lady said oh you're a Sam
fermented this guy's a confirmed suit
over here oh well sir this Claire's
Jeweler closed five hours send me my
ketchup oh God good good that means we
can do some after dark oh god well we
don't have a lot more time guys we want
to thank uh Pluto TV our sponsor uh so
disappointed that was uh the out of
warlock everybody Adam Warlock I know I
thought it was Adam fertlin Adam fart
lock Adam Harlock uh
oh that was that was a good mandatory
fight that was really great guys we've
met a lot of really interesting people
that was very fun right I got to fulfill
my dream of working four jobs
um
honestly the one that you did oh that's
it was unfair uh thank you to all our
super Chatters today uh J rhymney Leah
saying you are all the real super chat
this is for the money it's all the super
jets we met along the way uh thank you
Erica grunwell free Super Chat Daniel
doll uh Austin long saying think Agents
of Shield will be canonized and secret
Invasion that's where I would do it
little shrug uh do I think so absolutely
not secret Invasion has been dead or uh
I think Agents of Shield is dead and
buried producer John congratulations
now thank you
they're over there
John demanded or uh Jessica demanding
her horns I wanna I wanna say something
right now say it
we're so lucky though such great fans
watching this show every day and I want
to thank the chat for for offering
really fun and thoughtful comments and
so the Super Chat I really appreciate
what you guys do and I know deep down in
my heart that we couldn't do this show
if you didn't like And subscribe uh the
videos that we do and I hope right now
if you haven't in time you know in your
hearts and on your computers to just
inside your house is that I know you
live in just hit that like button hit
that subscribe button and you know maybe
make a guy with an old bitter heart like
me smile just for a few minutes of his
day
is Tommy turning face on the break room
against uh against the champion I'm
trying to adjust my depth perception
I just that's right I just really
appreciate you guys they took my eye you
know I want to thank my co-hosts oh this
is amazing time seem like I don't listen
and I just shout out little
non-sequiturs and I make this show my
own maybe sometimes but
um I hate it here I couldn't do it
without you guys and I'm so grateful to
have the best friends you all don't pay
me enough for this Tommy so stop with
the emotions first off Tommy's the
number one simp and I love that he calls
all of you guys Sims but look at that
that acts because he turned evil now
he's now it's made him good what
happened to you you used to be cool you
see he took his hair down damn it
my brother doesn't deserve to be king I
should be king I'm the one studying
I should have married my sister those
should be my incestuous children yes
I'm gonna go get a salad for dinner
tonight oh my what have you ever seen a
black man with an eye patch
besides Nick Fury the only black man
ever there's got to be a pirates and
Pirates of the Caribbean thanks Stevie
WonderWorks too
thank you Chef octopi uh Christian
unpronounce well everyone said I found
that really disrespectful
um
uh thank you all we hope you've enjoyed
the program today uh be sure to tune in
tomorrow here on the break room uh it'll
be Friday are we off the air I can't
talk to these idiots anymore
Friday will be great we might be in
costume you never know it gets a little
crazy on a Friday uh and thank you again
to Pluto TV we want to remind you that
uh they are the sponsor today for the
break room they got thousands of
channels uh you can check out thousands
of free movies on demand hundreds of
channels check them out at Pluto TV uh
be sure to join us here tomorrow make
sure you like the video if you've been
watching this far and haven't liked it
already uh thank you all for being here
today we'll see you tomorrow live on the
break room goodbye foreign
[Music]